[Music]
we're white more than 30 years of movie
theater experience between yes that's a
sin one of us was an extra in the last
cast one of us was actually paid to sit
in a comic book store selling comic
books magic cards action figures and
other nerdy items without having any
knowledge of any of those things while
the other once taught two semesters of
web design at a junior college without
knowing a single thing about web design
we're not reviewers or assholes hate
makes us stronger or like demons in the
Ghostbusters movie sins are often based
on things you will neither notice nor
will ever care to notice just like in
Catholicism our sins can be very minor
things the narrator's voice is annoying
we don't live in our mothers basements
because we don't deserve such luxury and
there are spiders down there the sin
counts have no real value because we
feel that if they did they'd lose their
real value people who tell us to get a
life or correct because we lost our
souls long ago yo soul is mine I once
got busy in a Burger King bathroom at
least two of the movies we've sinned
have been in our personal top 10 lists
even at number one and no let me stop
you right there
it wasn't mother fucking twilight
penalty at least one of us retires to a
sex dungeon at night and gets spanked by
a dominatrix like by reading dr. Seuss
books we're idiots 60% of the time it
works every time that doesn't make sense
those who think we don't read the book
you're going to be really pissed off
when we tell them that we read the book
just Twilight we did read the battleship
instruction manual from which the movie
was adapted the books do not matter we
censor our swear words even though we
don't have a problem with swear words
buster
you know hearty fight we managed to piss
off Ryan Johnson and Damon Lindelof but
Kevin Smith and Dane Cook are both on
our side
we're not sure what the net result is
there but until we have clarification
we're gonna call it a sin
we often sin when making our own videos
from bad boys too and people make fun
and we wear those sins like a badge
because that's the mother point even
some of the things in this video aren't
true some men just want to watch the
world burn King Kong ain't got on me why
was this call to Sinn féin does not
include lap dance you that's why we've
done sins videos for three Christopher
Nolan movies and not 1ue Bowl or brett
ratner movies we put our videos in the
film and animation category instead of
comedy because we've already given our
full allotment of fucks about people who
don't understand sarcasm we don't
understand Roman numerals almost seems
to happen I start playing Final Fantasy
seven one of us had seen the room five
times before we did our sins video in
the room the other one still hasn't seen
it which means we actively avoid
learning or caring about other cultures
we have never made a movie but we still
make fun of movies
[Music]
it rubs the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again
channel does not contain a lap dance
[Music]